From 2012 to 2016 our team and Microsoft
Research worked very closely with the
audio team at Gears of War and our
research help them build a product that
sounded more immersive in an
audio-visual sense it's about time we
get the hell outta here. Hey, are, we not going to talk about what happened back
there with the nest, I mean? What the
hell was that. It looked like they were transforming. Wait, you mean like evolving.
shouldn't that take a lot of time
computer graphics rendering is very
sophisticated it looks very realistic
but the sound up till now it has not
been that it doesn't respect the scene geometry. The amount of time
takes to manually lay out acoustic zones
is really intensive. Now a sound designer
can spend their time designing the sound. Project acoustics is essentially taking
the Triton technology and shipping it
such that developer or sound designers
can use it in their own titles. The
technique that we're using with wave
physics is unique from a an approach
standpoint. By using Azure batch we are
also using the power of the cloud to be
able to make this very complex
simulation take a lot less time. The goal
now for project acoustics is to
democratize this technology to get it in
the hands of as many game developers as
we can.